françois chevallier père de famille avec
sa femme ils ont adopté deux enfants à
la dass de paris il y a dix et sept ans
l'adoption est un thème qu'il connaît
bien
nous on vit avec nos enfants au
quotidien et on voit tout ce qui se
passe dans leur tête va tout ce qui nous
exprime ce que ne voit pas forcément
même les gens de notre entourage proche
donc tout ce qui a trait à la souffrance
de la séparation et ensuite tout ce qui
avait trait à l'identité mais nous on le
reçoit en plein trip à chaque fois perte
de repères conflit d'identité questions
sur leur origine
pour françois chevallier c'est un vrai
traumatisme que vivent les enfants
adoptés ce qu'ils sont en droit
d'attendre c'est d'avoir un papa et une
maman comme il aurait rêvé d'avoir
et rêver fait de pouvoir vivre avec
leurs parents d'origine à l'époque donc
tous les enfants vous moi on est issu
d'un père et d'une mère nos tours hausse
est essentiel de savoir qu'on est nous
les représentants de cette de ce couple
père et mère mardi dernier françois
chevallier a soutenu l'association
alliance butin venus manifester à
trappes contre l'homoparentalité
cette association se veut solidaire des
plus fragiles et place l'enfant au coeur
de ses préoccupations
un projet de loi souhaite ouvrir la
possibilité du mariage et de l'adoption
aux personnes de même sexe et nous en
sommes très inquiets parce que nous
pensons qu'à un enfant confié à
l'adoption a besoin d'un papa et d'une
maman un enfant confié à l'adoption n'a
pas le choix on va lui imposer deux
papas ou deux mamans cet enfant fragile
et sans voix ne peut pas se défendre et
dire qu'il a besoin de cette altérité
pour se construire
des rassemblements identiques ont été
organisées dans 75 villes de france
outre trappe l'association investit
trois autres villes des yvelines selon
allianz vite à près de 500 personnes se
sont rassemblées à versailles plus de
deux cents à saint germain en laye à
rambouillet cent trente personnes
auraient participé à la manifestation
contre l'homoparentalité